y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
proponer una pregunta pero quisiera
mostrarles un vídeo para que hagamos
preguntas y análisis con respecto a este
vídeo aquí les estoy mostrando lo que
son las reglas de uso permitido para
material que no es desarrollado este
vídeo es de un programa que se llama
feef
y es de un canal inglés channel five y
aquí arriba les estoy poniendo las
reglas en inglés sobre el uso correcto
de estos vídeos es para propósitos que
ya sean ajenos a la naturaleza comercial
y bueno nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es
usarlo con propósitos educativos este
también bueno la parte que se muestra es
muy pequeña de este vídeo no tiene audio
para que bueno nada más en la parte
matemática que es la que nos interesa se
puede ver y tampoco estamos queriendo es
criticar el trabajo original tampoco
queremos imponer o hacer que la gente no
vea el canal si ustedes quieren ir a
esta liga pueden ver el vídeo completo
sin ningún problema así que sin ninguna
crítica simplemente nosotros lo que
vamos a hacer es un mostrar no usar esta
parte para ilustrar y hacer un
resumen un problema matemático en esta
cuestión así que no tenemos nada que ver
con piratería ni nada por el estilo de
esas cosas feas
bueno entonces ahora lo que voy a hacer
es mostrarles en una pantalla chiquita y
como les comenté sin audio pues el vídeo
del que estamos hablando que pues
ustedes pueden ver en este en esta liga
aquí pues bueno estamos viendo que es un
piloto de carreras lo que va a hacer es
bueno manejar este auto queremos ver qué
velocidad lo maneja y calcular la
velocidad mínima que necesita tener este
auto para poder hacer un rizo vertical
qué es lo que vamos a ver que se realiza
este en el vídeo y después también vamos
a calcular cuál es la velocidad promedio
que realmente está usando este vehículo
para lograr pues está esta hazaña
entonces bueno ahorita vamos a poner el
vídeo
ahí está marcando
la velocidad va a estar por entrar al
rizo
entra entra el rizo en este instante
lo realiza y sale de él perfectamente
entonces bueno vamos a usar esto para
resolver cuestiones matemáticas en el
siguiente vídeo